in Giebelstadt in Unterfranken fahren
auf der B19 Tag für Tag 13 000 Fahrzeuge
mitten durch den Ort mit schlimmen
Folgen allein im Ortsteil euerhausen
gibt es bislang sechs Tote deshalb
versucht der Freistadt Bayern seit fast
einem halben Jahrhundert eine
Umgehungsstraße zu bauen die Behörden
planen planen und planen doch die
dringend benötigte Umgehung wird einfach
nicht gebaut die Anwohner
verzweifelt also mir geht's ganz
schlecht weil meine Mutter ist eine von
den sech Toten die hier auf der Straße
angefahren wurde und ums Leben gekommen
ist ich sag auch zu Freunden die soll
immer hintereinander laufen statt
nebeneinander in der Straße weil es sehr
halt gefährlich ist ja ich wohn seit 40
Jahre hier und das ist ja Witz ne die
Planung so lang Geld verschwendet ne und
da tut sich nichts in den 1970er Jahren
beginnen die ersten Planungen für die
Ortsumgehung für die Trasse kauft der
Bund rund 10 Hektar Land doch dann
werden andere Projekte vorgezogen der
Bau der Umgehung muss zurückstehen erst
2004 gibt's einen neuen Anlauf das im
Bereich der geplanten Trasse Feldhamster
und Wiesenweihe vorkommen also zwei
streng geschützte Arten ist kein
Geheimnis die sind schon immer da
trotzdem planen die Behörden munter
weiter 2022 stoppt die Regierung von
Unterfranken plötzlich das Plan
Feststellungsverfahren auf einmal gibt's
große Bedenken in Naturschutz in
Giebelstadt verstehen Sie das Ganze
planungswirw der Behörden nicht das
statliche Bauamt sitzt in der Regierung
von Unterfranken die höhere
Naturschutzbehörde sitzt auch in der
Regierung von unfranken und die
Planfeststellungsbehörde sitzt auch in
der Regierung von unfranken die hätten
sich nur im Gebäude austauschen müssen
die Regierung von Unterfranken teilt uns
mit die
atartenschutzrechtlichen Probleme wurden
erst durch das
Planfeststellungsverfahren
herausgearbeitet schriftlich heißt es
daher kann es auch vorkommen dass sich
im Laufe des Verfahrens herausstellt
dass einzelne Belange stärker betroffen
sind als zunächst angenommen viele
Menschen in giiebelstadt fühlen sich und
ihre Sorgen nicht ernst genommen wir
werden hingehalten und das jetzt schon
40 Jahre lang und es wird ja eigentlich
immer schlimmer für mich als normaler
Bürger ist es unverständlich ich frage
mich wie viel Geld da jetzt schon
verschleudert wurde und es geht auch
einfach nicht vorwärts in
Gesprächsrunden suchen die Behörden
weiter nach Alternativen in haben die
Menschen große Sorgen dass dabei auch
weiterhin nichts für Sie
herauskommt